to my wife
do you have a problem there's there's
just a serious thing going on in my
marriage just speak about it just be
happy I'm just going to be completely
honest yeah my marriage on the [ __ ]
rocks right now okay I'm looking for a
way out so she's like oh so you're not
gonna make the bed today and I'm like oh
well you know making the bed means I
gotta put 60 [ __ ] seven pillows like
in in an arrangement I didn't bite first
of all even one pillow I don't even want
one of these pillows I just want the one
that's for my head that's it but these
[ __ ] love covering the whole [ __ ]
bed all the way to the edge of the bed
to this I have a California king that's
a lot of pillows if you went to a
woman's house and she didn't have that
situation to be like why why aren't used
to marry me I'd probably say will you
marry me
I'll probably get on one knee and I have
[ __ ] tears for my [ __ ] eyes
because men don't give a [ __ ] about that
they're telling you about like the
Aesthetics you're goddamn right it's
practicality and that's it